Hales up guys my name is Adriano and
welcome to the first video the intro
video for the Sparky game engine series
so this is going to be a brand new
series in which we create a game engine
from scratch and the primary purpose for
this game engine is going to be full of
them dead
ok so for those of you don't know la dem
dere is a 48-hour game programming
competition in which you have 48 hours
to make a game from scratch based on a
particular theme now it is supposed to
be from scratch right and I really enjoy
making games from scratch in love and
air but over the years has kind of
evolved into you're allowed to use
certain game engines kind of competition
and specifically you're allowed to use
any library of code that is open source
and you're actually allowed to use game
engines such as unity and unreal now the
problem with that is that if I'm making
things from scratch and people are using
unity and unreal I can't really compete
with them so what I want to do because I
still do kind of want the entire game to
be made by myself and I enjoy doing that
I'm going to essentially make a game
engine for atom dare so that when I
start the actual competition I already
have a pretty solid engine slash base
code which will eliminate a lot of the
time of making the engine during the
competition and allow me to focus more
on the actual game which is going to be
great so this that's basically the
purpose of this series we're going to be
making game engine from scratch every
minute of development on this engine
will be shown the other thing I want to
mention is that it will be a live series
so you might have noticed the face cam
that I always do this during live
streams this particular video is in a
live stream but in the future I'm
probably going to stream this and record
it and post it to YouTube so that way I
can interact with the chat and with you
guys asking questions and I probably
will be able to answer as long as I
don't get too distracted I'll sure
should be able to answer quite a lot of
questions that are coming in while I'm
actually making the engine so that if
you guys have questions you don't have
to wait to the next video whatever you
guys can just ask me straight away it'll
be a great interactive experience this
is going to be quite an interactive
series and hopefully we're going to come
up with a game engine so we've got 45
days till the next let them dare to make
a game engine and
start today so there's probably going to
be quite a lot of content over the next
few weeks okay anyway that being said
Sparky is the name of this game engine
why I was streaming at one time and I
had a name and I think I went to like
some random name generator this came up
so and I really liked the name so Sparky
is the name of this game engine cool all
right
one thing I want to mention before we
begin is if you are good at art or you
know someone who is a good like artist
essentially and is primarily good at
stuff like 2d art so whether it be like
sprites assets you know backgrounds all
that kind of stuff for the purpose of
game development or they would or you
yourself or they would like to work on a
game development project please send me
an email because I really do want to get
some really high quality assets for this
so that we can test out this engine and
you know have it look pretty because
with my kind of pixel graphics it's just
not going to demonstrate how masses can
look so if you do know someone or you
yourself are a very talented artist and
are interested in working on a game
project please send me an email at this
email address which is my email address
okay so it's basically my full name yan
china golf but the eye is an outside
because that's awesome so there we go
that's my email address please send me
an email there if you would like to work
on a game project and you're an artist
okay cool that out of the way hopefully
we'll get some pretty awesome assets out
of that okay let's move on so I'm gonna
this is going to be the intro videos I'm
going to just discuss a few things such
as the technologies we're going to use
and I'm also going to ask you guys what
your preference is essentially so this
is going to be a as I mentioned is going
to be a fairly interactive series in
which we talk about in which I ask you
questions and whatnot and we actually
make this kind of together so that being
said the first thing we need to decide
on is that what what technology we're
going to make this game engine on so
specifically we want to start with
programming languages so we've got two
main choices right now we've got C++ and
we've got Java now this is not going to
be a c++ versus Java video because
if it was that could go on for hours but
I'm going to basically just plot out a
few things so the benefit of C++ so
there's going to be the pros for each
language is the fact that it's faster
it's a lot faster and it's also more
powerful and powerful is mainly what I
mean by that is in the sense of language
features so Java on the other hand is
going to be faster to dev so faster well
I'm right clicking everywhere because of
my freaking like pen that I'm man that's
annoying so there's this like button
right over there it's yeah and I'm
clicking on it every like second okay
let's just undo that okay so it's faster
to I'm just going to write dev so what
that means is going to be faster to make
applications with and it's going to be
faster to make this game engine in also
it's going to be easier and finally it's
going to be ah I want to say the
portability is probably going to be
higher what I mean by that is it'll work
on Windows Mac and Linux pretty much out
of the box okay cool that being said
let's let's just quickly discuss this
so C++ faster okay this is mainly due to
the fact that it's native code but also
because because of the fact that it's
native code it allows us to do a few
really really cool things to speed up
our application and just it's just it's
miles faster in the Java if you write it
properly obviously if you just write
rubbish code is going to be possibly
even slower than Java
but overall it's much much faster and it
gives us more control over stuff like
memory and whatnot so that's a plus
powerful what I mean by that is language
feature wise so stuff like macros and
I'm apologize if you guys can't really
see this part of the screen it's at the
face can but you know anyway stuff like
macros and the whole preprocessor thing
which is obviously a very big bonus it
allows us to configure certain builds
just turn off bits of code and
optimiser application and have some
pretty crazy stuff going on so that's a
that's a really big bonus it's also got
things like pointers and better memory
addressing and some of the libraries are
very good and we can even write assembly
language code in in C++ to do some
pretty cool memory hacks so that being
said it's going to be Pat more powerful
yeah this is going to be easier to write
in the sense that there's probably going
to be less errors
Java is a fairly safe language to
program in you probably won't be doing
too many things and C++ you can overlook
something in your application will
appear to run fine but it's actually on
fire
so that's a nother thing portability
Java
Java's whole thing is the fact that it
runs on you it's write once run
everywhere that's like their motto so if
you write it using if you if you write
it you know for Windows is going to
write it's going to run on Mac and Linux
as well with C++ we have to be basically
be careful not to use dependent platform
dependent libraries and functions and
I'll just even like build configurations
and so like that is going to be a bit
unfortunate so anyway that's kind of a
thing I honestly as of right now do not
know what I'm going to write this engine
in I'm going to let you guys decide okay
so post a comment below let me know what
you guys think I'm going to obviously
give you my opinion though in my opinion
is going to be C++ because it's
basically going to be a better engine as
simple as that
if it's written in C++ so but it will be
faster and we probably will get more
done so it's overall the C++ is going to
give us a better engine but it's going
to give us a smaller engine in the time
frame of 45 days obviously I'll keep
working on this after love them there
but remember we want to meet that load
on their deadline so we have something
to work with all right there we go so
that's my opinion
leave comments below let's get a
discussion going and we'll see what we
can do all right cool next I want to
talk about some of the features I
actually want to implement in this
engine so this is going to be kind of
our goals and I want to write probably
both goals within 45 days and just in
general like long-term kind of goals
that we have as well so a few things so
let's start with this we're going to
start with 2d okay it's going to be a 2d
engine I want to have no sorry let me
let me rephrase that it's going to be a
3d engine this capable of 2d so we're
going to start with trying to get Trudi
to work because it's simply going to be
it's gonna the development time for 2d
engine is going to be lower then it
didn't it's going to be taking us time
okay and since we are within a fairly
tight time frame it makes sense to at
least get the 2d working instead of
getting 3d and 2d kind of half done so
this is going to be our first priority
getting 2d working unfortunately with
the whole 2d aspect it's still going to
be 3d and the fact that I still want the
ability to load in 3d models but we can
view them in a 2d projection or
something and that shouldn't be too
difficult at all that should be easy but
in terms of 2d I do want to have a
fairly fast and solid
2d renderer ready to go at the end of
this so 3d is going to be kind of kind
of the the I guess the next step so
we'll make sure the 2d is working and
we'll slowly start integrating 3d into
it as well ok cool
the next thing I want to do is I wanted
to be as a bare minimum it should work
on Windows right if we have time and
whatever Mac and Linux and axed of
course we write it in Java this will be
out of the box if we write in this if I
slice it probably won't be I'll try not
to use too many windows API dependent
things or exclusives
but yeah the other thing I would like
that this is more of a long-term goal
but I do want it to run on the web so I
do want it to run on the web browser and
inside like a web browser so we will
have will have to one thing I should
mention is it will be using OpenGL but
the other thing is if we do want to have
it on the web we'll need something that
will essentially port the OpenGL into
WebGL and we'll also have to restrict
ourselves to earn the using WebGL
features anyway it's going to be a lot
it's going to involve a lot of work to
get that
happen if we do end up using a C++
there's something called M scripting
which is actually pretty good I've used
it a few times it works very well
basically it will compile you'll sleep
loss loss code into JavaScript and your
OpenGL code into WebGL or it'll even
emulate glass 2 which is OpenGL ES or
embedded systems which is what's running
on your phones and mobile devices but
essentially um Emscripten is actually
pretty good I've used it a few fair few
times just for but it emulate it's got
it basically essentially convert C++ to
JavaScript it's pretty good it's pretty
crazy and it runs faster than JavaScript
because it uses a few length uses like
what I think it's called a s MJS or
something it uses like a um
Mozilla's like ultra fast JavaScript
kind of hack thing to make it run even
faster than JavaScript so it essentially
runs almost like native code it's pretty
cool it's pretty crazy so this might be
a real possibility if we do use it less
plus the other thing I want this is more
of a long term goal so these are kind of
the things I wanted to be very fast so
the 2d renderer at least should be just
lightning fast I want to be able to
render stuff like fifty thousand sprites
easily on the screen at one time so
that'll be our kind of beginning goal
fifty thousand sprites at like 60 frames
or whatever on a fairly moderate
computer but um we'll move on from there
and we'll see how good how good we can
make this but the point is I want to be
really efficient which is so obviously
leaning the favor of C++ as well all
right cool ah the other thing I wanted
to mention was this is more of a
long-term goal as well kind of like the
web thing but I also want to be able to
use this engine I want to be able to
write games for the engine in c-sharp
Java or C++ so the cool thing is if we
if we write this in in C++ then it's
actually fairly easy to set it up so
c-sharp we can link it via CLI Java we
can link it via J&I which is going to
not be as good as CLA but it's still
going to be kind of okay and simple
ossicles is the actual language that's
fine Java does not really allow you to
use it as well objects so we'd have to
basically wrap them all in functions
which would be a pain but
could get it working essentially CLI
will let us use objects so she's the the
c-sharp asleep C++ combination is pretty
good and then the question you know that
begs the question why do we even need
job for using c-sharp and partly of
course c-sharp is pretty much a better
language but unfortunately it doesn't
run very well on not Windows so the
honor there's mono framework you don't
need to lecture me about that but the it
just does not work as well okay cool so
that's our plan so this should be a
pretty versatile engine as you guys can
probably tell I'm gonna pretty much wrap
up the video there I don't want this to
go on too long what do we are like ten
minutes twenty minutes almost Wow
well 115 but anyway those are the main
features okay
we'll be using OpenGL we're obviously
going to use my modern OpenGL I'll be
trying my best at support three point
three as a minimum if we do go on to
WebGL dough that will unfortunately mean
we'll probably have to drop to around
two I think because OpenGL es2 so glares
too is I think about equivalent to WebGL
roughly so we'll have to unfortunately
sacrifice a few things but as I said as
a base we're going to be going for
Windows so we won't be we won't even be
thinking much about this I'll try again
as I'm running the code I'll try and
make it a not-so platform dependent but
that we want to get this out as a
minimum so this is kind of we're not
even going to think about this when we
start writing mansion too much okay
we'll kind of have it at the back of our
minds but not too much all right cool
so that's our plan that's the master
plan for Sparky so let's talk about how
this is going to happen so one thing I
want to mention is this will be open
sourced you guys are free to use this
for Adam Darrow for whatever you want
basically it'll be under the GPL license
I'm going to put it on github so when I
record episodes and I update the code I
will be pushing it onto github there's
actually a engine already here called
Sparky I renamed it as Sparky test this
was something else messing with it with
a live stream this our engine will be
completely different to this Sparky
engine so don't I wouldn't copy this
code and
assume you will predict the future of
what I'm going to type because this is
something completely different basically
is what I'm saying but um if you want to
follow me on github or whatever the
repository will pop up here called
Sparky obviously link it after every
video and whatnot but that's what it's
going to happen and finally one thing I
want to mention is twitch.tv four types
of channel is where the live streams are
actually going to happen so hmm yeah
go ahead and follow me there and then
all of a see follow me on Twitter as
well - it'll come for /the Cherno to
stay up to date with pretty much
everything and every time I stream I'll
be posting on there as well
so anyway those are that's basically how
this is going to happen I'm pretty
excited
we've only got 45 days so let's make a
game engine